es un día histórico y aquí en alemania
según el principio de jurisdicción
universal el corte de koblenz acaba de
anunciar su veredicto en el juicio al
khatib se halló culpable y le dio una
sentencia de por vida a anuar gestión un
antiguo coronel del régimen sirio de
bashar al-assad quien fue juzgado aquí
en alemania por su responsabilidad en
crímenes contra la humanidad y actos de
torturas en más de 4.000 casos y en al
menos 58 asesinatos cometidos en las
cárceles de damasco entre 2011 y 2012
durante un año y media víctimas
sobrevivientes y sus familiares habían
testificado de eso y además pruebas
forenses de hecho más de 26 mil
fotografías forenses fueron presentadas
durante este juicio este momento se ve
como una fuerte señal no sólo por las
víctimas no sólo para la comunidad
internacional sino también contra la
impunidad del régimen sirio